My name is Dan Korsun.
I'm studying physics here
at MIT and my research
is into the effects of
radiation damage on ReBCO
high temperature
superconductors.
So ReBCO stands for rare-earth
barium-copper oxide.
And it's a type
of superconductor
that we're looking
at here at MIT
to build the next generation
of fusion devices.
So nuclear fusion is kind of
like making a star on earth.
It's replicating what
the sun and other stars
do to produce almost limitless
amounts of clean, carbon
free energy.
And so here at
MIT, we're actually
building a new
device called SPARC.
And SPARC will be the
first fusion device
to actually produce more
power than it takes to run.
And SPARC will do
this by actually
using magnets for
the first time made
of this material called ReBCO.
And ReBCO is a very,
very special material.
So it can actually-- it's
a superconductor, which
means it can carry
incredibly high amounts
of currents and under
specialized conditions.
So here we actually have
a traditional copper cable
that you would see a
traditional fusion device.
And here we have a
little piece of ReBCO.
And under certain conditions,
this little piece of ReBCO
can actually carry the
same amount of current
as this big copper cable.
And that is what
enables us in SPARC,
and in the future, such
devices to actually produce
such large amounts of power.
And so what my
research focuses on
is emulating how the neutrons
produced in fusion reactions
will actually damage
ReBCO and impact
its performance over time.
And so very little is
actually understood
about how ReBCO will be
damaged by such neutrons.
And my work is actually
focused on applying reactor
relevant irradiation conditions
like low temperatures
and high fields to
these ReBCO samples
to emulate and predict how
such magnets will perform over
time in fusion
devices, which will
impact the viability of
these devices going forward.